conmoción en Argentina la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner salió
ilesa de un presunto intento de
asesinato un individuo levantó una
pistola contra ella y apretó el gatillo
cuando Fernández saludaba a
simpatizantes agrupados frente a su
domicilio el arma con cinco balas dentro
misteriosamente no detonó querido pueblo
argentino en el día de hoy poco después
de las 21 horas un hombre atentó contra
la vida del actual vicepresidenta de la
nación y dos veces presidenta
constitucional
Cristina Fernández de kirchner
este hecho es de una enorme gravedad es
el más grave que ha sucedido desde que
hemos recuperado nuestra democracia
la policía detuvo el sospechoso y lo
identificó como Fernando Andrés abad un
ciudadano de origen brasileño de 35 años
el oficialismo llamó a la reflexión
decretando feriado nacional en tanto
figuras de la oposición como el ex
presidente Mauricio condenaron el ataque
mi repudio absoluto al ataque sufrido
por Cristina kirchner que
Afortunadamente no ha tenido
consecuencias para la vicepresidenta
este gravísimo hecho exige un inmediato
y profundo de esclarecimiento por parte
de la justicia y las fuerzas de
seguridad del resto del mundo llegaron
también mensajes de rechazo a lo
ocurrido los presidentes de chile
Gabriel Colombia Gustavo Petro Perú
Pedro Castillo Venezuela Nicolás maduro
y Ecuador Guillermo lasso están entre
los muchos que repudiaron el ataque
también lo hicieron el Papa Francisco y
el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony blinken el intento de
atentado se da en un contexto de tensión
en el país en las últimas semanas en la
fiscalía solicitó 12 años de cárcel para
la ex magnataria así como su
inhabilitación de por vida en cargos
públicos por su presunta participación
en contratos millonarios corruptos con
el estado tras ello multitudes de
Seguidores de Cristina Fernández se
congregaron en las inmediaciones de su
residencia en Buenos Aires en señal de
protesta en las últimas jornadas se
habían producido choques contra la
policía y detractores de la
vicepresidenta